hello freak [ __ ] yeah the community
thing I think is like a key thing yes I
just I recently did a debunk of a UFO
that the Chilean Navy supposedly saw
what was that I'm not aware of that way
it was it was like this just think that
there was a Chilean Navy helicopter had
this infrared camera and they saw this
this black two black dots off in the
distance that looked like a weird thing
like like a figure eight type thing
flying away and then it done it like
spraying out this stuff and they
couldn't figure what it was and they
chased after it but it was too
fascinating going away from them and the
Chilean government has an official UFO
investigation team and they they set
them on it and spent two years figuring
out what it was and they couldn't figure
out what it was and so decided to get
its a confirmed unidentified object and
then they published their findings and
then I and some other people on Medibank
looked at it and we figured out it was
actually just a plane flying away from
the helicopter leaving some contrails
behind and we actually figured out
exactly which plane it was and so
they've got there's got a bit of fly on
line and there was on like cuttings and
posts and things like that and some UFO
enthusiasts started talking to me and I
joined their groups and I joined a few
of the groups and then I found myself in
this kind of weird corner of the
internet where everybody believes in
UFOs unquestioningly and they're always
putting up these photographs of things
and people are like are great caps dude
and it's just something like street
light or something but they think they
had this this confirmation bias this
group confirmation bias yeah where they
can't disagree with someone and they
know they're in a safe space so they can
put out whatever theory that they like
and they know that people would be like
they're just very supportive of them
yeah one that happened a couple of days
ago some woman put up a picture of a
strange light that she said was in the
sky and so I downloaded the picture and
I boosted the brightness and a story was
actually a reflection or
something in a security light on a porch
and you could see it was like there was
trees behind in terms of security
lightness reflection so I posted that
and then I started getting called like a
shill for pointing this out yeah there's
a couple of people that like that oh
yeah it's just it's light but other
people were like well why don't you
believe me why you would like in
validating like you know my claim right
and so they once I had these kind of
little walled gardens where everybody
believes the same thing that's a good
way to put the walled gardens it really
is a good way to put it that that is
what those community seemed like and
that's one of the things that I found
when I did that television show I I
still harbored a few conspiracy theories
before I did that show but doing that
show for several months and constantly
interviewing people who believed in
outlandish things I found the same thing
over and over and over again
illogical people with very little
evidence believing things in almost a
religious way and I found it with
Bigfoot and I found it with UFOs and I
found it with chemtrails and I found it
with it was just one after the other in
varying stages of ridiculousness feel
like contrails and chemtrails were the
most nutty people UFO people seem to be
the most reasonable because it's the
most reasonable theory out of all of
them the idea that we have spaceships
why doesn't someone else have spaceships
there's hundreds of billions of galaxies
in the known universe hundreds of
billions of planets in each galaxy the
odds of there being some sort of a
life-form out there it's pretty high but
there's nothing that's the craziest
thing like the more I went into the more
I talked to these people the more I went
over all their evidence air quotes
evidence the more I asked them why they
believe things there is nothing there's
not a goddamn thing you could put on a
scale there's nothing you can weigh
there's nothing that you can measure
there's nothing you can look at a photo
and go wow that's compelling
there's not one there's just an idea and
that idea is that there's something in
the sky that flies around that we you
know either might catch if you're there
the right place the right time or not
and that they're from another planet
like yeah I could look at what they put
forward the best evidence is often likes
nothing cases from the sixties where
there's an eyewitness who said something
I do some guy on a road who says he
blacked out oh yeah like you know
kaga messed up it's always that from the
sixes well that's the other thing that I
know too much about psychedelic drugs
and I know about endogenous psychedelic
drugs the brain producing this chemical
called dimethyltryptamine that happens
when you're sleeping now they've proven
that this stuff is produced in the liver
and in the lungs and they believe it's
now they've got evidence that it's
produced in the pineal gland is a very
potent psychedelic drug that your brain
produces and your brain produces it
during REM sleep so these people they
all take naps and during these naps they
have these crazy [ __ ] dreams and it's
entirely possible that during these
dreams what happened is they got some
endogenous DMT dump whether they were
under stress or whether they just had is
the erratic dump of this human neuro
chemical that entered into their
bloodstream whatever it is it caused it
all these [ __ ] UFO abductions all of
them like almost exactly happen at night
and they happen all these people are
sleeping like wouldn't you just assume
that you were dreaming why why wouldn't
you assume you were dreaming yeah I have
these I used to have these kind of night
terror hallucination things we should
kind of like that yeah it was always the
same type of thing it was like a giant
spider who coming down from the ceiling
towards me and I wouldn't move I was
like you know frozen for a second then
out then I would then I would jump out
of bed and turn on the light and look
for the spider
there's happened all the time like and
you know I knew because there was no
spider that it wasn't real but I could
see if someone was having a different
type of hallucination there seemed a bit
more real and then you know it maybe
it's a it came in between sleep cycles
for them then yeah totally yeah you can
see it seemed completely real yeah I had
I used to have it all the time and it
was always liking it was horrible it was
this like giant really realistic spider
and he wasn't like you know I was
dreaming somewhere else I was in the
room and I could see it like I was
seeing something crawling across the
table right here was his hallucination
hmm I don't really eat them anymore idea
what it was brains fixed itself or
whatever but well it's probably a lot
has to do with being young and confused
and hormones and nerves and and then
also like your brain starts filling in
the blank you want a very good
understanding of the universe you know
your brain your imagination runs wild
it was very confusing to me doing that
television show and it really changed me
a lot and it it changed me the point
that people started accusing me of being
co-opted by the government the
government threatened my family and told
me to stop talking about conspiracies
like and then the idea that I wouldn't
say that if that was the case like you
don't think I would [ __ ] tell
everybody if someone threatened my
family because I was talking about UFOs
I'd be telling everybody I'd be like hey
man I would tell all my friends I'd be
like dude he [ __ ] threatened me
because I was talking about UFOs this
[ __ ] is real hangar 18 county 51 and
those are paper a while ago published on
like how many people it would take to
cover up certain conspiracy theory of
and the probability of none of those
people ever talking yeah and it's just
ridiculous like you can't have tens of
millions of people in on a conspiracy
what do you think happened at Roswell
Roswell New Mexico the one that's the
big one
by 1947 a UFO crash I think it's what
what I said it was it was a that those
balloons that they were using to detect
Russian nuclear bombs in the atmosphere
and it was a secret program so they
weren't allowed to tell anybody about it
so they came in they picked up the
remains of the balloon and then the
story just took off that's a funny one
though boy that's that's made a whole
town famous for UFOs if you go there now
they have like alien themed gift shops
and milking it it's like I said earlier
like people make money out of something
and then they get stuck into us you know
because they're making money out of it
they're motivated you know to you know
promote whatever it is Bigfoot or if
it's aliens have you ever seen anything
in all of your years of trying to debunk
these things that made you question
whether or not this was a legitimate
phenomena what the chemtrails anything
anything anything beautiful camera real
thing it's like with with UFOs there's
all things that you can't explain there
are things that are right inside that
there are there's usually plausible
explanations for them right I like to
like whenever I'm given something like a
mysterious thing I like to list all the
explanations that I can think of and
maybe none of them are perfect fix the
bits that you can guarantee this is what
explanation is but like it being like a
or an alien spacecraft as an explanation
is usually pretty close to the bottom
like you start out saying oh it's a
balloon rather it's a bird or it's a
drone or it's CGI or it's you know it's
something something somebody fakes
afterwards right or it's an alien
spacecraft nor in between that like oh
it's something else that we don't know
what it is is there any evidence like in
terms of UFOs that's interesting I have
you know to be honest I haven't really
looked into the whole sphere of UFO
ology I know a lot of people have but
just looking at the quality of the the
best cases they put forward like I
mentioned earlier like you know some guy
in 1964 like got his car beat up on a
road right these are like the you know
top 10 best cases and this was like
number 2 or something what about Bob
Lazar you were looking at that guy yeah
which was he laughs those are the guy
supposedly know supposedly worked at
area 51 became a whistleblower and now I
haven't but you know a lot of that it's
something you see in the 911 community
is and in the chemtrail community is
people kind of becoming celebrities yeah
and then they kind of start going on
road shows and you know they they go to
conventions and they speak and then they
write books and then they start doing
things and they they get sucked into
their beliefs
[Applause]
[Music]
you